[Music]
News on fuller House Stark Jodie Sweetin
love life and it's not that cool all bad
actually
yeah you know she's been divorced three
times and she was headed to the altar
again but that seems like it's over now
after some very dramatic developments
news that sweeten called off her
engagement to Justin Hodak comes
following two weeks of chaos at home
Friday Hodak was arrested for the second
time in six days after violating an
emergency protective order et has
obtained the order it contains explosive
allegations sweet'n claims on March 18th
Hodak a convicted felon stormed out of
their home with a nine-millimeter pistol
threatening to use it following a
violent argument Sweden called 911 s
Tain's arrest on a gun charge the papers
say police confiscated an illegal
assault rifle before the protective
order was granted she also alleges he
made 87 calls to her cell phone
et spoke for Jodi a week before that 911
call when she walked the red carpet at
the Kids Choice Awards with a broken leg
your fiancees here tonight right we
haven't yet yeah like every time we
think about it just it keeps getting
pushed a little bit further so we'll get
through the broken leg first I mean
honestly this is a good enough excuse
yeah do you have any plans a dress or
anything and ring nothing yet
[Music]
you